hi you guys it's your little slug i'm
coming on the road i'm coming on the
road cut that
she's a come queen cut that you'll hear
why
you'll hear why that's really she's
going on the road
um i'm coming to florida and i'm going
to be at the improv comedy theater in
tampa
on october 12th i'll be october 13th in
orlando at the orlando improv
and october 14th i'll be at the dania
point improv
uh in dania beach florida come see me in
florida i'll be adding more dates soon
and also check out sleepoverbyester.com
for some cute
things that are coming out this week all
right guys
i am back on the road having so much fun
i sold out my first show at flappers
on july 15th so we added a second one at
10 pm check that out get tickets before
they sell out
then i'm at wise guys in utah july 16th
and 17th
i'm doing a special event at the lincoln
the lincoln financial center which is
where the eagles play in philadelphia
on 7 29 and i'm at the buffalo helium
7 30 through 8 1. please come see me
it's so fun i'm doing a bunch of shows
in august too
um please go to my website
andyletterman.com
and you can also get my new dana devito
merch thank you
wait can we talk about that is this for
doll face what
your hair yes yes i just i'm very proud
of you for taking back the night
from doll face they did you so dirty
last night
for people who don't know season one of
doll face i got the haircut from hell
and it was um i tried i tried to talk
you down from it but it was
everyone tried it yeah it was it was but
here
i i have an opposing view i actually
think you look really cute with short
hair just not the first
cut it was really rough and it was at
you know how everyone has that line
where it just like does the flip
it was yeah your eyelashes look cute you
little munchkin
little camera it's like a girl yeah the
girl drew
we know the hair was done a couple days
ago though no this was today
this is okay but delilah because you
even said
that jenna showed you the bad haircut
and you you don't have to talk about but
yes like the version no we're talking
about it it was bad
you know you guys don't was bad this was
not just like me like wait because i'm
chill about hair i try i really like was
like no no no we could make the best of
them
i think i cried maybe i think i cried
too well here i think jenna cried when
she showed me the picture
and only because i think version 1.0 of
the short haircut was
not good this was like it was cuter
yeah they fixed it is it a different
hair person or the hair oh that hair
person
was gone like from the earth very
quickly
not even because the mind delivered not
even because of what happened with me
like i was what i'm not
so you were just a part of it yeah i was
just a victim
and this in the whole scheme of it but
yes they
so the thing with the show is it's all
it's four brunettes and i'm the lowest
on the totem pole
so i'm the one that got a little bit of
it's cute
it's like kind of 90s blonde too that's
what kala said
what are you you should try to get a gin
try to get them to chunk it
yeah i chunked it in the front in high
school i had that too because of the
kelly clarkson
album cover did they paint it on as a
balayage or did they put you in a
in one of those hats it's i think it's
balayage because she
painted it and then foiled yes okay is
that what you get what do you get your
hair colored
yeah what do you do i guess sorry to the
guys
they listen they get to hear it all
um i get yeah they paint it on they like
paint it each piece and then they put
foil over it
yeah and sometimes they just put like um
cotton balls and plastic wrap but
what i think i've seen that um do you
have
color contacts in too no oh my god your
eyes look like
you're becoming christians it must be
them and your nails look better yeah
they made you get boring nails last time
this is huge life upgrade i know like i
feel like when i'm on a show i actually
act like a
like i'm supposed to act like you mean
they cast you as a woman and you have to
play one
they're so long and thick oh my god
esther wait did kelly clarkson have the
chunky
yes oh my god yes but it was also like
wasn't it like flat ironed very straight
this is the hair i copied in high school
can i see that you also copied the
lounging too
how gorgeous in the ugly
is this hair i know it's so weird and
it's all coming back
it is it's fun it's fun to be this age
and see it come back
yeah it does mean we're very old
for sure
[Music]
for sure because what bell bottoms came
back in the i never thought that i'd do
the day can i
um tell you it came back in high school
can i tell you guys why i was late today
it's so good yes randy i took randy to
the groomer
and the groomer is taking four hours
because he's giving randy
a mullet i was like you want to give him
like a funny haircut
like uh and so it took so long and i
went back to i went to vanderpump so
that's like by my old house so the guy
thought i was just like at my house he
didn't know that i moved to the west
side
so he was just like kind of like taking
his time and like trying to make sure
randy had a good experience he wasn't
like scared of him
and then i like came in like two hours
later he's like oh i'm so far from done
and i was like so now he's dropping
randy off
at my house so i had to drive back
and then drive here wait is that true
he's really getting a mullet
how can a dog i'm so excited
i was thinking like a bowl cut i mean
it's gonna be so cute and it will
we'll cut it soon i smell a viral moment
a dog with a mullet he's a star he needs
to have some like he's special
you should have him on that one show um
with rebel wilson the dog grooming
conversation yeah
guys can i just tell you something
really real i i forgot to draw on my abs
and i'm so insecure
i've been drawing my daily drawing on my
abs and it's really changed my life
you know i'm not gonna lie like if you
if
it looks real like when you when you're
on cam
when you're on camera it looks real and
if you're not looking too closely if
you're just kind of it's like one of
those
i highlighted it too though that's why
it's and i gave myself an eight pack you
guys saw it was like
it was a ten pack it was like a pack
nobody yeah somebody was like oh this
she did she painted her abs like the
movie 300.
but you're right it's it's like true
artistry because it actually it's
like true camera makeup you're like
you're so fat it's like true artistry
you're literally so obese that it's like
no but honestly like i
and i wear i went to abba kinney and i
was oh by the way i have to tell you
something afterwards
secret time about that but um
i'm not for you guys you can hear it but
not for you
but i one i had like in my head i was
like oh i'll just do like a joke like
abzukini and draw them on
and then they weren't like dark enough
so i just was
chubby on abikini but i figured it i
just
photoshopped it over but i've been going
out in public just like full out with it
painted on very obviously one day
they're gonna label that appropriation
of something
abs drawn on apps oh also
i got a a company is sending me the neck
machine that joe rogan used to get his
neck thick because
it will help with my tmj but if i end up
with the neck thick
the neck thickness of joe rogan will you
guys still do a podcast
no no we'll do audio only
but i already have the voice of someone
with a thick neck so i already have a
thick neck voice okay i have an
important question which one of you
said that your hall pass was liab
schreiber me
that was you yeah i totally thought it
was clyde okay so
last night i was watching spotlight
which is a really good movie
like it's genuinely a good movie i
should have seen it by now
liam schreiber for the first time i was
like oh i see it oh i love it had to be
a bunch of children got molested before
you could see leave schreiber was hot it
couldn't be of any of the other movies
no but it was that he played like a
jewish like
how about when he was wolverine oh i
didn't see that but i wanted to ask you
what movie did you see him and that made
you like him wait also
you've seen three movies and one of them
is the molester movie
you're like oh i'm ready to break out
and watch some more movies does anyone
have any of the most depressing movies
of all time
schindler's list i love the theme song
it's
no that's my 600 pound life bobby and i
[ __ ] to that all the time i just started
watching a show like that yeah it makes
me so horny i don't understand my best
show like that i think it's like the
thousand pound sisters
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's pointing to you
comment i've seen that one it's like the
the two ton man and then the halftime
the sisters
have you seen the viral clip where the
woman's like the doctor's like so what
do you guys
drink and then they're like sodies oh
and like i relate to that yeah do you
guys know what a feeder is
yes the enabler that feeds them yeah
they get off to feeding well no it's
it's actually a
fetish that some people have yes but
you're not wrong esther can you be both
but let's suppose like one day i have
dreams of just
saying [ __ ] it i don't care about my
looks i don't care about anything i just
want to eat whatever
but one day um like for instance my
friend asakira
she's um she's a famous porn star right
i saw her on the show show right so she
always talks about one day just having
this fantasy of being really really fat
and her husband just like feeding her
whatever she wants and i think there's
something really kind of romantic about
that
in a very um unhealthy way but like
there is like when i think about it i'm
like that is like ultimate freedom
todd would do it it it is but i always
think then about like
how sick to your stomach you have to get
to like gain that much weight like you
get through it your body
stretches you're like you'll figure it
out yeah you're gonna
but i agree like when dave would like if
i wasn't feeling well and dave like
brought me a bowl of popcorn
i that's like i'm like oh like it just
like satisfies something within me
he brought me food but i we need to go
back to something you are
horny at 600 pounds can you explain um i
don't know what it was i don't know if
it was just like circumstantial but when
bobby and i first started dating that's
all it was on was tlc
like half ton man and all of that and we
would always just like
do these like the sex is it because it
made bobby look really skinny
[Laughter]
is it because it reminds me of like when
you first started dating and you were
super attracted to each other
i think so that just happened to be on
in the background and
we just left it on well we would like do
things so i was like okay this works and
so now when i see it i'm like ooh the
nostalgia
you have a pavlovian response i do and
you get you want to [ __ ]
i do i'm pavlov's dog do you want to
like [ __ ] on like plates of
greasy food slide i'm not a food and sex
person i don't understand
like is it are there really food and sex
people
sure there's everybody people i have a
version of that that's not
exactly but when i eat a big grease like
if i were to just eat a big cheeseburger
fries i like how that changed
if we could imagine that happening
imagine a world that's so crazy
that's this girl with this hair that was
obviously done by someone else and
forced on her
if i ate a big plate of fries and a
greasy cheeseburger by the way and uh
oreo milkshake
my dream meal i would be like all right
let's have sex
can your dream meal be a meal you have
every day esther you are a minority
there
yeah big meals and sex right after isn't
that i know it's
she's disgusting it's like burp and fart
on him it's like no
it's like it's like oh i'm already like
gross like let's do the next like gross
sloppy thing
like let's just go i'm so the opposite
of each other
do not touch me if i've had like even a
quarter of a minute
i just did my no it looks fine i'm on
nothing
i love how you're just like freestyling
it
yeah ew that was like by the way it
smells like an oreo milkshake
and come ill sorry i said come i know
it's a triggering word
we say go go go go i know [ __ ] is
disgusting
comes great it's not well wait you're
both wrong
jizz is like a spawn word what about
spunk
spunky but it's like grosser spunk is
[Music]
i like when guys say i'm gonna bust but
that's
oh my you know why it's quite trash
though yes that's what boys and
timberlands
yes by the way another reason i was late
was because i went like the mulholland
driveway and there's some sort
i'm guessing it's a rapper's party
because it was a bunch of like really
well-dressed black people and then
well and then white people dressed like
well-dressed black people
and like cops were like escorting people
and i was like oh my god something's
going on here
somebody's busting and somebody there
busting plus bus is good finish
oh it seems proper yeah it's that seems
very gubernatorial
that would be esther's can you tell me
if you're about to finish are you
finished sir is it time to have the
milkshake
have you finished on my stomach yeah
what about skeet
do you ever are you ever confused of
whether it's um oreo
milkshake or [ __ ] oreo cream are you like
wait why was the oreo in there
what if it is crusty on well i'll just
stop right there
the elmer's glue over there reminds me i
had a friend once who would
it always reminds you it does because
okay everybody
no because you know what i think about i
think about um that scene in girls do
you remember when adam driver was
hooking up with that i can't remember
the brunette girl who was in um uh the
show
uh roswell i think it was the same girl
oh and he was like
yeah he was like dating her and then he
like brings her to her house and he's
like get on all fours and crawl on my
bed and she's like okay
and she like reluctantly crosses the bed
and then he's like he's like banging
everybody like flips her over and it
comes all over her chest
and she's like i don't like that i'm
like oh that sounds fun but um
i always imagined they used like elmer's
glue or something because you saw like
fake like there was an art department
that had to be like grab the elmer's
glue for that
i do wonder what they use for that again
perhaps some
cornstarch that's so explicit to have to
make fake come
mm-hmm i know really i feel like i want
that job
like a fake maker yeah i had a friend
who used to should we have a contest of
making fake home next year yeah oh my
god gather the
ingredients i'd nail this i'd really
nail this super soaker
but my friend would open would go up to
girls and it was the most
inappropriate way and he would say when
are you going to let me skeet on your
back
did it work it probably works it worked
every time
come on i've never heard skeeter skeet
come on little john
oh skeet skeet [ __ ] oh skeet ski
god damn
like when you skate and you slide a
little bit
when you hide your plane while you're
skating
it's when you skate on the street skeet
you know what i will say and i know this
is like
whatever my [ __ ] family listens but
um i i know i'm like squeamish about the
words around it
but that said if it's like on me
and it dries up i can go days and i just
don't care
i mean that's i don't think that's a
testament that's just you how badly you
don't want to bathe
that's on brand esther okay no one is
surprised
also i have your ballester i need that
bella
[Music]
by the way if your parents were just
half paying attention the minute you're
like i know my family's watching they
like perked up they're like are she
going to bring me up
and now they're going to be like washing
your clothes more that's good i'm going
to go ahead and say at least for this
room you're very alone
are you serious yeah i don't want that
[ __ ] dry [ __ ] like
remnants of i don't know yeah oh you
don't care either shut up [ __ ]
swimming up
like i'll take the wet spot let's go
let's just go to bed who cares
shake the wet spot i call the wet spot
i just don't care you know what it's not
like a chemical
it doesn't taste like it's sometimes
chlorine it smells like that to me
sometimes it does taste a little like it
smells like all my traumatic years of
being like a swimmer i think that's why
i want it off of me
yeah dry swimming pool it dries my skin
makes my eyes burn
and then it's almost like it's like the
way to still feel like young and [ __ ]
when you're like out around and you're
like oh yeah there's like
that's over there i'm imagining you
elderly like just like jizz in your
[ __ ] skin flaps
sprinkles everywhere i'm sorry go go in
your laps
oh esther look i'm just gonna start you
know what maybe you are the [ __ ] queen
oh my god no oh my god esther the come
queen
get me
dave next time to make it a sash across
you oh my god
you cannot say things like that we're in
i'm going to retire
the d word
our next merch line two slugs and a come
queen no
no i am no she's a slug but i feel like
she's the only slug that doesn't shrivel
up and die with jizz on it
it moistens me makes me thick and makes
her
dance um
have you guys ever thought that you were
psychic yes
no i'm not an idiot listen stupid listen
dumb [ __ ] listen to this
listen to this listen to this story i'm
in a bar
in new york city it's after i quit
drinking okay i'm dead sober
i'm sitting next to some dudes talking
[ __ ] you know how i just chat do crowd
work with just random people
just nobody's listening i'm just like
i go what do you guys do they go we're
drummers i go oh you guys are drummers
like in a band they go not really and i
go what are you blue men and they go
who told you we were blue men and i was
like wait you're blue men they're like
yeah we're blue men
i was like are you [ __ ] with me they
were [ __ ] blue men i just knew they
were blue men
they weren't in an outfit they were just
regular guys just blue man group
yes wow i just guessed it out of [ __ ]
nowhere
okay we need another example why are you
i believe her because i
i honestly do feel like i'm
deeply connected to some things like for
instance and i hate to be there like you
wore a blue shirt knowing i was going to
talk about it exactly
also so if you look through my phone's
notes
i write every time like i suspect
there's going to be like a major
earthquake in the world
and i text it to my mom and my sister
and i've gotten it right every time
that's so scary including the worst one
in haiti
can you start predicting not earthquakes
predicting nice things like why do you
think you're
able to do that like what are you so i
don't know what it is since i was seven
years old
or the fact that we live in a freaking
san andreas fault line so like i could
predict
one right now be like someone and of
course there's gonna be some like
movement in the earth so
but i think it's just a coincidence so
when i was younger i did this but maybe
you liked your knees shake
i i don't know i my mom and sister
believe me now i believe you
if i don't predict predict the next big
one then i'm wrong
you guys we're all going to be on the
move this summer i think we know that
i've been on the move i can't we all
have been moving
and getting like five times first class
um my advice to you if you're going to
be flying is to take your raycons with
you first class or economy
but seriously you guys a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears can make
all the difference in your life
i know you were wearing them on your
flight yes i was
you get crisp powerful beats at half the
price of other premium audio brands
rakons look great and feel even better
they come in a range of cool colors and
with customizable gel tips
they are included for a comfortable
in-ear fit
and raycons are built to go wherever you
go with quick and seamless bluetooth
pairing and a compact charging case
when i see someone wearing them i'm
always like oh they just got really good
quality and save money so like i respect
that and you know what i really love
about them
not only do they actually sound really
well but they they give you
options because my ears are very finicky
and they're very sensitive and
surprising
i know swimmers here anyways um but they
give you different option sizes for your
different ear holes so you just choose
one that fits you best
i really appreciate that they have 24
hour charger too that's really good
i hate when they die and also i had the
more expensive brands and i kept losing
them and it's
[ __ ] humiliating you can lose these
and get another pair and still feel okay
with yourself
and still fly first class with annie
listen up raycon's offering
15 off all their products from our
listeners and here's what you've got to
do to get it
go to buy raycon.com trash
there you'll get 15 off your entire
recon order and it's such a good deal
you'll want to grab a pair
and a spare because you might lose them
if you're like one of us
that's fifteen percent off at buy recon
dot com slash
trash by raycon dot com slash
trash
[Music]
have you guys heard of this book many
lives many masters i think that's what
it's like the famous book about
um reincarnation and like people who
who believe in that and stuff oh my god
i thought it was about master's degrees
i was like
please don't make me go back to school
when i was
this is a real insight to what a freako
i was when i was younger but i got like
really into like
death and like the afterlife and all
this stuff when i was probably like
12. and it's so cool i know cool dude
waffles rule yeah dude let's have a
picnic in the cemetery
so but this book there i remember there
was a section in the book where is it
because you look like you're in the
adams family or
oh what an icon my idol wednesday out of
i know
oh you thought it was wednesday oh
um but there is this part in the book
where it talks about like if you lay
down
like it was almost like telling
explaining meditation like you close
your eyes and you just like think
nothing
and you're supposed to like visualize
like psychic you're supposed like
have some type of psychic ability and
i don't know maybe the end of your story
that can't be what the book said think
of nothing and then what
and then like basically okay here's why
i said it because you're supposed to be
able to just like lay there
and like if you follow their
instructions i won't go go to dry honey
you're supposed to like have a psychic
you're supposed to like see
figure something out wait but yeah you
got like in tune with yourself i don't
believe that
i do that i think if you if you power
down you're more
heightened to other things around you
like there have been times and bobby
will tell you
where i will like wake up in the middle
of the night like a whole minute before
and i'll wake up a bit earthquake and
he's like there's no earthquake and a
minute after there will be an earthquake
okay that's weird but i think that's
just
highly sensitive like feeling like i
probably felt a shake before anything
i you know that i've i have talked
through every earthquake
and i wish this was a [ __ ] i'm not even
kidding i've never heard an earthquake
because i talk so much that i'm just
chatting chatting chatting chatting
people i think they're like really into
my story or something i'm like oh i'm
like knocking them off their feet
and then people go to earthquake i'm
like are you guys [ __ ] kidding me you
know it's like
i never saw a deer when i was whatever
and i was like dear i'm like wait are
you guys [ __ ] with me
like i always miss the deer and i always
miss the earthquakes i've never once
felt
but that's a gift in itself is that the
fact that like you would probably talk
through any calamity
that's what she's like a good per if
you're on the titanic and it's sinking
yeah hang out with her you won't even
know you're drowning
i'm like who even likes balls get rid of
them
hold that dick back let me get at those
balls ew so esther
what is the big news in your life what
is your big brand new purchase
okay so as you guys know i have been
driving a 2001
toyota camry for as long as i've if you
got a tesla i'm going to be pissed
shout out to camryso because my first
car was a camry as well wait what year
is it
2001. speaking of i watched spotlight
last night and saw my 01 car all over
that movie because it takes place
that's right and they're probably hard
to find they're like can we does anyone
have one anymore
they use her car attention movie
producers i'm keeping my 2001 camrys so
if you need it for a rental for your
next big production
i will say i didn't see your car out
there so
i this summer i'm working on a show
where
my commute is an hour like uh an hour
there an hour back and i was always
annoying me too like it's time
and i i really wanted a tesla
like part of me i like got tesla fever
for a moment
and i looked it up and was like okay
like it's pretty expensive
but you know i've waited this long like
maybe i'll do it
but then they my debt first so i told my
dad your dad said no
my dad freaked out was like you're
paying for the name you're paying for
elon musk you're an
idiot like you're just paying for his
name all this stuff
and um and then also they weren't
available
and they're not available until the fall
yeah so i went with my big dream and i
got myself a 2021
toyota corolla oh my gosh hybrid
wow i think that what color applause
break
[Applause]
well you know that gets dirty fast
safest car on the road
honestly let me you know when we went to
palm springs i drove my mom's corolla
and the whole time it's a 20 20 20. okay
because she just got and i the whole
ride there i'm like this is the best car
i've ever driven this is where
i [ __ ] do toyota's for life toyota's
i got tricked into getting a honda but i
never wanted to get rid of toyota that's
what dave has the civic
which it's still nice it's just not a
toyota it's just
close but it's just not but i also think
all cars are the same like i really do i
think
you've only driven the same car that's
why you've never even
ventured out you've had there's two cars
you've driven
now three i know and my my dad was like
he was like okay well now you'll have
this car for 20 years and i was like oh
my god this is crazy
but that's why i bought i know most
people did you pay all right oh right i
i bought it so i said alt-right for some
reason
i bought it so it's not least because
the thought of elise freaks me out
personally because i like to destroy my
car yeah no it's really rough
i like to turn them into a beater why do
you are you does that
you lease i lease and it's just i just
i'm like
we'll deal with this later it's just
like oh this is going to be a problem at
some point let's decide for like
yoda's later my dream car is an el
camino have you ever seen those
no wait i think they're like the
no it's just obvious there was no
surprise in it
look because you're getting banged in
the back like yeah
el camino's the one that had the back
goes like that yeah oh
wow yeah isn't that in that movie that
tarantino movie where they kill
everybody
that's all tarantula movies it is in all
of them that's what i meant
we have possibilities but to me i just
see a car with
it's an older car so you've got problems
yeah yes
but if you switch out a lot of things i
think well look it wouldn't be something
i drive
every day don't get mad at us but i
don't want your dream i don't drive
every day i'm a freaking
home buyer don't you not have a car i
buy cycles
you buy cycles
now listen what color do you want um i
always thought of getting a white one oh
wait
either a midnight blue oh love that or
um a white one for some reason with like
a salmon on interior
would you do oh that's really cute would
you do like uh details on it
um i don't think so i have yet to figure
out exactly what i want would you want
the stripe up there
but would you guys go on a ride with me
we won't be going very far
maybe well we know your mom would be
with you
rudy
[Laughter]
one thing about my new car not to brag
all the windows go up and down
you're not gonna get hit on anymore and
it has backup camera
it does i did notice i people are
honking at me
in this car and i think that they never
honked at me my last car because i
was like my our friend john always says
the scariest person in the room is a
person who has
nothing to lose and that that was me in
my old car afraid of you
people did not [ __ ] with me that's
exactly why i'll never will never get
rid of this prius like it has like
bullet holes through it it looks like
the person who owns this car
has is bobby parish was on
mad tv wait but you're you you guys have
one car right one car
or a one car family and you he i'm
assuming
he's he owns it and abuses it right yeah
but then um
jules has her license now so she's a new
driver she's hit a couple things
does she tell them well no she's only
hit um
things like don't yeah like not other
cars no people so far thank god
but she's definitely did you see that
video the whole under part got like
scraped off
and bobby was like ah it's okay did it
start out as a lease and bobby's like
i'm gonna have to buy this [ __ ]
dude bobby rented a car from enterprise
for a whole year you guys
why can you spend like twenty
i'm paying like the same price for this
shitty car yes
but i think that you guys are similar in
that way where it's like the
inconvenience there is no price
i mean he would rather pay that price
than be inconvenienced guys
if i was rich i would take a [ __ ]
helicopter to this podcast
i do not that drive is so rough well
here
it's just unpredictable it's like
unpredictable that's the annoying part
you know there's like a famous story
about your partner bobby lee
that he couldn't find his car
so he just forgot about it and bought a
new one oh
that's that's actually the milder
version of events
he bought three i mean it's happened
right before my very eyes i know it was
my birthday was this one he was still
using
oh it's so good this is over bobby as
sober as as
as he can get he picks me up from the
airport um we drive back to we're about
two blocks away from home we're really
we could literally walk home
called triple a we both have triple a um
his car stalls
it's something minor it's not something
wrong with the computer he says babe we
just got to leave it here
we'll buy a new car tomorrow and i'm
like are you [ __ ] crazy we got into
the
biggest screaming match because he was
insistent on not getting it towed
my judicial theme is to have bobby lee
throw away money
he doesn't i don't think baby you just
are wanting bobby lee throw away
yes yes he doesn't we didn't even have a
lot of money then he was just like i
just i
can't do it i can't do it i gotta go i
gotta leave like he just wants to leave
the scene and never think about it again
leave the scene
flee the scene what kind of car was it
it was this prius does bobby wait he
tried to
flee this prius you still have it and we
still have it does bobby have guilt like
if he were to leave the scene could he
just
stop thinking about yeah you can drop it
and i judge that i wouldn't be able to
do that
at one time his car flipped over a
couple times in the freeway
sorry that's not funny with bobby and it
is
so he flipped his car a couple times in
the freeway is it like separate times or
like it flipped a couple times in the
same way at the same time
okay so it he totaled it but he was able
to crawl out dust himself
off and he was like huh i'm gonna go get
a taco bell so he goes walks over to
taco bell
and and then comes back to the scene of
the his [ __ ] you know
destroyed vehicle and paramedics and
cops are surrounding it
and they're like sir sir don't come any
closer there's a dead body in there
and he was like that's me this is why
he's my hero
but he was probably in shock honestly um
because i've gotten in some car
accidents and you're in full shock
and you don't you do crazy things maybe
or maybe he's just like i don't what's
the big deal guys
like everything's fine i'm alive i have
you know tacos in my hands i love this
man when he crashed
into sam tripoli's car it was
though were you there literally i don't
know but the video is their favorite
thing i've
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever seen
it's my favorite thing i wish it would
happen every day
explain why he so slowly crashed into
the car it was the slowest
[ __ ] roll ever and like i
love sam tripoli but he's like a [ __ ]
spaz but he's also a spaz with a heart
of gold that will get over it but in the
moment
it was just so good how personally he
took it
it was just and and if you think about
it it's like bobby you did [ __ ] do
that on purpose
um well do you guys really because it
went so slow you could put the [ __ ]
it was really slow and it's just and
just something about the red rope and
just what sam's wearing
everything's just something why are you
not getting this look up and he's got
his little angry hands
sam you're [ __ ] sorry
so he had relapsed here obviously yeah
um but he was going through
he was keeping it a secret from me
nobody knew at this point that he had
relapsed
he was being very like erratic i almost
thought that he was going through like
some mania
i remember telling him like you're
either on the verge of like a [ __ ] his
dad had just died i was like you're on a
verge of
a breakdown or you're back using i was
like which one is it eventually but i
didn't know at this point
but when i found out about this or i
found out that he had relapsed
later i asked him i was like did you do
that on purpose
and he was like i think in my head in
that moment
there was a part of me that like blamed
sam tripoli for relapsing i was like
okay
you know that's not true like you should
be blaming yourself yourself only like
there's no one to blame here
you know what i was hoping you were
going to say that bobby did it on
purpose because he thought it would be
funny
because he was high and thought it would
be funny i'm sure that was something
honestly it's so funny and look at sam's
outfit
like you're supposed to get your car
crashed
wait so he can you explain that like he
was
mad at sam yeah like he was
subconsciously mad at sam because i'm
just
blaming him for his relapse yeah so i
think that he says that there's 20
of him that think that even though it
was
an accident it wasn't as accidental as
maybe his subconscious was i see
was inactive deep in there yeah which is
a stupid cop-out
explanation for why you would hit
someone's car and i if i were a hampton
played before
not if it's the truth i mean if that's
the truth of like how you felt
yeah really it's just accepting
responsibility for being an [ __ ]
but he he did he did pay for the for
that asked her what were you doing at
this moment masturbating
i was probably talking to tony tony was
like
i've seen a last car crash i saw was on
stage earlier
i i want to talk to you guys about
something i've always wondered but
that sounds scary like we were in
trouble no no
i was like what you are in trouble i
always feel in trouble when someone asks
me this but have you ever been a
bridesmaid
yes and have you enjoyed the process
yeah but i was lucky because it was a
covid
well i did almost die no she didn't have
to do her makeup she could wear a mask
i was the coven bride made it i was a
covid
i was technically the co-maid of honor
but it was just tricky
there's a co-maid of honor yeah this
means that everyone
was like esther we know this is your big
day but
we do need someone else but i'm involved
i want to know if you guys think it's
cool that like
they're expected to pay so much no i
didn't have to pay [ __ ] it was my
brother's wedding
he knew i was paying nothing that's how
to do what i feel like if i'm sorry guys
if i'm ever getting married
and i'm asking you guys to be in my
wedding party i'm not having you pay for
anything
only because it's like if i don't have
that money for myself i'm not going to
burden my friends about that
right well i think that's different
because we're we're co-workers i but i
i i think there's times where it's okay
but i
i agree that it's insane it's so much
money demand that kind of money but
i would only do it for someone who i
would want to do it for i felt so
like personally attacked by the dress
that i was given because i was
i was a bridesmaid in both my brother's
weddings and the first
it's like you guys know i have sweaty
armpits like you picked this color with
that cut
i'm like i'm gonna be pitting down to
the i'm gonna ruin your [ __ ] pictures
i just realized you're the reason in the
universe
why i had to be a co-bride's maid
because
christina's husband's twin sister
had to [ __ ] be the co-bridesmaid with
me oh yeah because i'm the girl yeah so
the sister
yeah oh don't you think you're wrong in
this though
yeah always putting yourself above that
twin really
like there was a womb i wanted you we're
not in i really want to be in that womb
but we should make oh my god we should
make an ultrasound of you just clinging
to the outside of the womb
[Laughter]
what constitutes like a bridezilla like
would you
okay how do you turn down someone who
says will you be my bridesmaid they give
you the whole letter they're teary-eyed
nobody likes nobody wanted me involved
in these weddings this was like they
were like we gotta do it and by the way
it's my twin brother
but do you see why no one wanted the
other co-bridesmaids she's proving it
right i just have a feeling you were the
one they didn't want but it's fine i
want you to feel what you feel and i
want to be on your side but i know you
and i have nothing against his twin
sister you looked beautiful
and you're wonderful but this was my
moment
so my brother did not this was like
right when i was starting comedy so my
family i was like this
always but i was didn't have tv credits
so they were this was very unacceptable
right like when it was like there's no
way this is gonna like pay for the
college of the children in my family
they were like you're bad but the minute
there was like oh we might be getting
some
money out of this foul mouth like that
it got good but so this is before i even
did like chelsea lately or any of those
things
so i was just doing like open mics and
just still like running my mouth
so i was not allowed to give a speech at
my twin brother's wedding
and i was like destroyed for years like
i am 100
over it i completely see their side i
know exactly what they didn't want me to
say and 100
i was opening with that and i was
probably gonna call it back at the end
too so like there was things they didn't
want me to say that i was gonna say so
they didn't but their excuse was they
said we're just letting the maid of
honor and the
best man give speeches and that was her
sister and my only other brother so it
was all the siblings except me
well is it can you say what it was that
you weren't supposed to say that you
wanted
no i can't i've already i've already
said it so many times and the only
reason i can't say it again is because
my sister-in-law has a real job and i
said it once before
and then one of her co-workers came up
and was like oh that thing with your
husband like my son has that and she was
like
annie i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you what
could this i'll tell you all
i'll tell you off wait but so okay the
last wedding that i went to which was
amazing it was like a platinum wedding
i'd always wanted but
i didn't know anybody else in the bridal
party and to me that's a problem yeah
like that's when it gets difficult and
then they're like we're all going to do
a dance and now i have these strangers
what kind of dance oh it was a it was a
bollywood dance
okay and at first i was really like
amped i was like yeah [ __ ] yeah i'm
going to be
yeah i was really like but after i
realized that
i had to take instruction from these
professional bollywood dancers and the
way they were giving me instruction i
was just like all right like
now i feel obligated and it just i lost
the fun and i opted out
oh okay well that's good because you you
don't want to ruin the you don't want to
be no i was like
you're supposed to go right or whatever
this looks like you guys are having so
much fun i was like i'm going to opt out
of this was that when you had the bad
yeah i also felt very um uh
how did i say i don't say this out loud
because of my friend's wedding but there
was some mean girl
energy in the bread they were not warm
to me at all
that makes me mad and i'm just like what
did i that makes me want to yell at
those girls and unfollow them and be
mean girls to them
but you guys know me i'm not exactly
like i'm like oh i'm pretty i'm a pretty
warm person but they were very um
they were not about that how good does
it feel to just press that opt
out button and sit back and relax i got
some pushback though
i was like look i'm not [ __ ] dancing
and um i got another girl to
um get opt out with me as well
thankfully she was like an indian girl
so i was like [ __ ] yeah
if an indian girl is going to opt out of
this that means i'm not did you buddy up
yeah yes yes because i do feel like in
the mean girl situation there's always
one girl that's like
i know you're being mean girl yeah i see
this happening
it's [ __ ] up there's always like one
person that's like yeah and
trying to save you and and and i love my
reality i love my friend who got married
but it's like come on like you know
be part of the bachelorette party and
i'm like i'm not gonna go to mexico
for me with a bunch of girls i don't
know
you know what i mean it's hard girls
trips are rough you it's a it's such a
like uh
you need it to be a good balance yeah
i'm not going to pay that much money
to to be around strangers yeah
uncomfortable
and then since you're the odd man out
you kind of have to like it's up to you
to kind of like
insert yourself which is yeah so that's
such a tricky i've definitely been
yeah if i had ever been invited to a
girls trip i would totally agree with
you guys
but well maybe with your new hair and
eye makeup
you finally uh jumped in are you gonna
have a wedding are either of us gonna
have a wedding you guys are not gonna go
because it's gonna be in the philippines
i said
we were i'll go
for your wedding of course i know but is
it gonna be um
would you feel like pushed no would you
like well she will feel pushed because
there will be a wheelchair involved she
will
have some sort of injury i'll tell you
who'd be really excited as dave
dave loves traveling and he would love
like so
and i'll be happy like to be going with
him yeah i
can i just tell you i i don't expect you
to change who you are
ever but i and i like who you are i
think you have very strong boundaries i
really appreciate that
about you but i do think i just had an
experience on vacation
that was like very like kind of like
eye-opening and changing and i think
that you could come around to vacation
i agree i like where's we we're supposed
to go to puerto rico i know you were
just there for
christina's maybe bachelor what
she was coming out of a [ __ ] murder
scene in puerto rico i
just who did she need my puerto rican
friends like i haven't discussed this
with my puerto rican friends yet because
i really
i don't know what's cultural and what's
just because of the pandemic and because
of like the natural disasters that have
hit puerto rico like
i don't know what is just like how they
are or like what
what is just their like because okay it
took like two hours to get food like you
would be like at a restaurant take like
two hours for them to even like
get your food or anything and then like
we went to this one restaurant and they
like
the chef like after two hours we see the
chef like run by with like a box of
frozen foods and we're like
wait you're supposed to like hide that
under an apron we're not supposed to
know
and like they just like handed this
place but it was also this one
restaurant and then i was thinking like
is this customary or is it because they
were under unemployment as well and it's
like they're under staff
because people are still getting paid i
have noticed that a lot of restaurants
and i
have a longer wait time right i think
that is covid related yeah
um and i do think they are understaffed
maybe they're like a chill like whatever
like i went to the concierge at one of
the places we're saying
i know and it was raining and i go what
do you do when it
rains for fun she goes we potty we dance
and i was like
it's like 8 am [ __ ] like where like me
what do you i just mean like today what
are we gonna do
and then but i didn't know that it just
like rains and stops raining and rains
it's raining like i was planning the
rain the entire time
i had just like soaking wet extensions
the entire time
but we it was like it was really fun and
i just was i
this is what i realized i want to be way
more respectful when i go to places like
i want to like learn about the culture
i want to know the language better it
was surprising how much spanish i
remember though it was crazy like what
were you saying i want to know i want to
know
what was i saying yeah well i thought i
only knew palabras malice right
yeah which gets yelled at me at shows
because i said this on here
but i just knew words like i just knew
like difficult
like i just knew how to like say like
breakfast and [ __ ] like there were just
like things that would just pop
up and i was like oh i could probably
just dual lingo this [ __ ] and
learn a lot of stuff but i felt like i
didn't want to come in and be like
we need our food now this is [ __ ] up
like i didn't want to judge a culture
like if the culture is chill
that's like my bad i should come in and
fit into there
well let me give you um a preemptive
like warning then if you go to the
philippines if you think puerto rico is
slow
we move slower i'm not food service
necessarily but it's like it is slow
yeah and [ __ ]
spam isn't it it's not that hard chop
chop chop
treasures things like lines and stuff
let's say if you go to a grocery store
you you know over here they just uh the
bagger will just put everything in a bag
and you go no over there they'll put
things in a bag
and then they'll roll it a couple times
then they'll they'll print out the
receipt they'll staple the receipt
six times it's like they more con do the
yeah but it's almost like
that's unnecessary yeah it's like
they're doing these extra steps and
things just move a little slow it's
either
you absolutely love it and find it cute
or you just lose your mind yeah
so that's a warning for you guys i love
it i think it feels like home but there
are moments where i'm in the airport
where i was like
get out i can look at esther's like i'm
piggybacking her she'll be fine
i definitely like things that move quick
especially when it involves food
or like engagements or moving in
together
or yeah like committing your life to me
i always think of the first episode
season one episode one of the girls next
door where they all went out to dinner
with
hugh hefner and all the girls were like
so
when the food doesn't come right away
like hef gets really grumpy like he
needs his food right away and i'm always
like that's me
i'm like you hefner at a restaurant is
probably diabetic and at this point like
his sugar is dropping i could see you
just eating stuff in a grotto
because it's all wet i just relate to
that like i relate to being like yeah i
like when my food comes right i don't
know
how badly she wants anna nicole smith
next to her at all times
yeah i try to be i do try to work on my
patients because it's like what that's
like a meat problem if it's
you know yeah i should my piece is like
up to me but when you're hungry
it's really hard they have that thing in
um
[Music]
in a a that's called halt it's like
hungry angry lonely tired so whenever
you're upset you have to check in
you have to halt who do you check in
with yourself yeah all right what do you
tell yourself
am i hungry angry lonely or tired but
maybe you're on my period
by the way are we allowed to out that we
like did a bunch of
episodes together and that's right yeah
yeah yeah everyone keeps being like why
is she annie on her period
every week and i'm on my period again
but it's because we do like
we had to cluster them because of
traveling we banged them but so it was
i know also i didn't know that gum was
an issue i was having nausea and then it
wasn't until one came
like we had already recorded five and
then like we were like oh [ __ ] so
there's no more gum i'm better i'm
healthier now it was a health thing
we're learning as we go and we're gonna
apologize as we go
but also like okay so then some the
reason i wanted to clear it up is
because
some girl was like some women just have
their period all the time it's like
i'm like no i don't i mean i did when i
got the depo shot i did on my page
yes but that hasn't happened to me in a
while wait shout out to
my friend jenna i don't think she'll
mind saying this but she's had her
period for six months
that's right right she didn't have it
for like a year and now she's not
like everyone i know has pcos it's so
common yes it's a it's a lot more common
than we think but
she's just she's like i don't understand
why like
i feel because she's not used to having
um monthly periods
but is it okay it's not like okay
because this is i don't want to get into
this propaganda chat yeah anything
but i am not sure but i have a little
bit of a weird feeling that my period is
a little bit changed since i got the
vaccine what oh really
it is i have fudgies in the beginning i
never used to have that
and it was like right after i got it
right after
no i mean here i think that travel
changes in your routine changes in
exercise intensity
there are a lot of things about that
that's been
intensity we've been flatlining there
there are a lot of things that could
contribute to like period changes right
like even for me when i can't when i
come back from
six months out of the country and i've
had like long 24-hour travels right
my period is delayed for two weeks yeah
or pooping
yeah it's it's weird but it any changes
weird when you travel
it is oh do you have travelers
constipation who doesn't i do
i have travelers diarrhea well you're
not supposed to drink the water [ __ ]
it's called dysentery wait i'm trying to
think because
okay i know you guys love the word
fudgies i personally don't subscribe but
that means like it's like it's worth it
you're the most fudgy-ish
it's brown and chunky right it's just
brown and streaky
yeah streaky that so that to me that
means it's like older blood right
that's better but what would cause that
um actually it sounds like you're just
spotting
um that to me sounds like spotting um i
think that it could be anything
it could be you know if you say my age
i'm gonna [ __ ] choke you out
you'll die [ __ ] you and i are the same
age [ __ ] i'll take you out
i went to [ __ ] oh my god you guys i
went to medieval times
okay i went to medieval times and i is
this an attempt to unage yourself
no no no no no no listen what city
there's one near wherever not lots
farmers
i've never been more scared of my life
than when i went to medieval times and
i'm
in middle school for the field trip i
didn't know like
if it was real and what was it are you
serious you're a [ __ ] actress
you don't understand roles you don't
understand how dumb i was for a very
long time
did you think heath ledger was going to
pop out of one of the
i was very scared of course you loved it
listen can i just tell you i was a
little pissed my first thought my night
was fat
and old okay my night was
was barney he was cool i still liked him
but
he was the bigger of the
bunch and the older of the bunch and i
just he died second
and i just felt like he didn't they
didn't give enough time to rest
because even his like sire or squire or
whatever
they like he was kind of like out of
shape like i don't know like our crew
was just the out of shape crew and i
know they just came back from covid
how does it work you choose a night and
they compete with each other no they
give you like a
colored hat oh and then you sit in that
section
so and then it's already predetermined i
guess but
there was like one guy that was like
this hispanic guy that was all like
ripped and he came in second
he was kind of evil and his team was the
coolest see people
die like that's scary how old are you
when you went to medieval times that was
very fake
12. i mean it could have been yesterday
and should have the same feeling
it's scary did you like like is the food
you know what i kept thinking
that horses look like randy everybody
looks like randy i'm sorry but a fat
night sounds really hot to me look
this is very controversial it was very
hot he was very sweaty the hottest
person in all of game of thrones
was robert baratheon he was robert
baratheon style yes he was he was
definitely that weight
maybe a little less but graybeard and
here's the thing he did do good there
were a couple
challenges that were that are not
predetermined where they have to like go
and have to get their joust through
these
these rings and some people get them
some don't he got both of his rings like
he was good
but he was a little winded and they just
give him a break they didn't give him a
break and i know it was probably already
predetermined but they didn't give him a
break so even if it wasn't predetermined
he was gonna get killed
do you get a present if your guy wins no
but they do like point to like certain
women and give them roses and he pointed
way past me i was like
uh i was wearing my neon skins too i was
like you can't miss me
i'm like i have more followers than
these people so if you want to get on
instagram
but what i wanted to tell you the reason
i thought of this is because i went out
todd and i went out to get drinks
and i got a horn i got a virgin pina
colada and a horn
so if i have it at my house i should
have brought it to drink but um
so we're this woman was working as the
bartender and
they have to speak in like the old
fashioned dialect so they're like uh
what can i get you milady and then she
was like oh milady you're so pretty
and your boyfriend is so handsome doth
my lady have children and i go
oh no but maybe sometimes she goes um
well one better hurry and i was like
to todd i was like no
no no no no no no she's like do it soon
i was like okay thanks wench where's my
[ __ ] give me my [ __ ] drink
she did not say i swear to god and i was
like uh and in my head i'm like trying
i'm like spinning it any direction that
it could be
but i was like i was wearing a mask they
might wear a mess i'm like she was
you know it's like the mask does
accentuate the crow's feet i was like
this [ __ ] was just like that is your
eggs are shriveling insane
that is this i went i went well back in
uh the time of
the lord they did not have frozen eggs
[ __ ] okay now give me my frozen pina
colada it was just like so crazy
it was so good i need a banana break to
digest what happened to you
[Music]
so i think i now know why i love fat
guys
what do you mean like i'm horny for fat
because you lost your virginity on water
bed
that's why because you like watching
that show will you have sex so i was
obsessed then one of the number one um
sports that i watched growing up was
sumo wrestling with my dad
and so like i was obsessed like i would
see that these
sumo wrestlers like takanohana or
akubono
they would they were like in the front
pages of a lot of like
japanese magazines and they were always
with like um like
um supermodels like asian supermodel
girlfriends
so my idea of hot i think is
influence and that's the reason why when
i look at bobby
and i know that i want him to be healthy
but i do kind of like him
when he's fat you're a feeder or
whatever they're called well i just like
the shape a lot
dude do you want to put him in like a in
like a cloth diaper
i do you're not into it yes no i love
if a guy is skinny for me like i just i
need them i need weight i need
meat i need fat i need hair
like when i watch a man but not on the
top of the head
when i watch a man eat something like
big and nasty like
i can't even think of what it would be
but like something where i would never
eat i'd be like ew
that's hot too what please tell me what
you would need like anything like
like i don't eat crab legs
i'm trying to think of crap the greatest
foods of all time just watching a man
eat i don't know what's a disgusting
thing to watch people eat like
watching a man eat something disgusting
i'm like oh yeah like hell yeah that's
hot
would you get turned on if you saw me
grab like twice a day
speaking of uncle fester i was obsessed
with
his vibe his look everything about him
when i
watched adam's family and what it was
not go mad
that i loved it was uncle faster i've
never heard it sound like there's a guy
named adam and it's his family you're
like adam's
family
it's the wrong and fastest on the wrong
side guys how's it doing sweating
i am sweaty you guys well it was really
hot oh so surprising that she's like i'm
like you pigs
but well here's the thing the upside of
being in like humid weather
is that you're never just sweating out
of your pits you're swimming from
everywhere but it's too much when every
pore is wet like i just can't
it's just it's too much i was in the
humidity i did
i surprised my dad for his 80th birthday
party
by the way getting trying to find
outfits to wear on my family is
so hard because i feel like jennifer
aniston going home for thanksgiving i'm
like
literally my full shape of my tits is
shown in every outfit i have
i was i mean i i was like about to just
put duct tape on my sister-in-law at one
point was like
i'm sorry is the like is it too cold in
here and i was like what are you talking
about she was like your nipple and i was
like they were pierced when i was 14.
i'm sorry i was like oh just like like
i'm just surprised my nephew didn't try
to breastfeed but
um we surprised my dad for his 80th
birthday
and it was so cute my brother drove down
with the girls from boston
and we all stayed my older brother used
to have like a really small house in
philadelphia
and then for the equal price in jersey
he gets this like huge it's so beautiful
this great backyard and stuff
so i could tell he was really excited to
like host all of us so
my brother and i came the night before
my dad's birthday and we slept over the
kids all slept in the same room
i had a little air mattress it was just
like really cute and then
um he invited my dad was having a
birthday party and then
at four so he invited him for brunch at
his house
and he came down to the basement to see
the boys and i popped out of like a
kid's tent
and my dad was hoping i was gonna
surprise him but i've been lying to his
[ __ ] face for like weeks that i
couldn't come
so i popped out which is like to be
expected because i surprised everyone
and then he was all excited about that
and then behind him the bathroom door
open and then my brother and the girls
came out and he was just so happy it was
so cute
and then we went to my friend my mom's
friend amanda i guess she's my friend
too i've known her a long time
her house and it was like all my friends
i've had like
i've had a shift where i've realized
i've been being really judgmental of
people
sorry guys at george i'm still a little
judgmental of your haircut
but i really like have been noticing it
today well take a [ __ ] shower you
look like yesterday last week
um but i really like have been paying
attention to that and i've been thinking
about it
and i was realizing how much i was
judging my family and like even with
their landmark and all that stuff so all
their landmark friends came and like
my dad does this new warrior thing too
so it was like all these like people in
these different groups that they do
and they just like all love each other
so much and they
love my parents and they like we're
doing like drum circles and all this
like
they have like low ponytails it was just
a little pony
and they just like step dad's into that
too yeah they love
my parents you know and i like since we
had like we had a talk you know like
since we had our talk like i really like
i saw my family twice since then and it
really like changed my experience with
my family so i do thank you guys for
that talk
and i just like realized how much i was
like judging my brother for like i was
like
expecting my brother to be a certain way
to me like
like my twin brother's supposed to pay
more attention to me or or something
like that you know and then
you know i like spend time with him with
releasing that and it was just like so
much nicer and such like a good
experience and not expecting him to be
anyway
and then he
won an emmy he won his second emmy and
it's like he's been busy he's like
not it's not like he's ignoring me he's
just working and like paying attention
and like what am i going to do what i
what do i have to even to say to him
like do you call it jizz or go go like
what do i have to say to my brother
and sometimes too i feel like you know
we're
the people we're closest to or we love
the most you almost neglect them first
like you know i'm the first person to be
like to my mom like shut up [ __ ]
like it's so funny to call your mom a
[ __ ] it's so nice shut the [ __ ] up
her [ __ ] moves will never be up front
they'll always be very secret
it's just easy to so i could see maybe a
world where your brother probably loves
you
but is like i don't need to [ __ ]
check in you know yeah she knows
yeah [ __ ] you you know like i i really
relate to that i think that's probably a
very
common thing it's like the people you
love the most you kind of
like or like even dave it's like i'm
like go do whatever you want you know
like
i don't need to talk to you today but in
terms of like your
popcorn but i think that's really
awesome the fact that like you know
you've been skeptical about like your
parents
like relationship with landmark but it's
like ultimately
to see that it simply just makes them
happy and it brings joy to their life
is enough right yeah and we shouldn't
sort of like insert ourselves in other
people's joy
yeah because it's not our place to like
dictate that and it's also like to it's
like me
saying like the way that i think is the
right way and the way that someone else
thinks is the wrong way and it's like
the it's the whatever i'm doing is the
right way for me
yeah and whatever they're doing is the
right way to correct and like like
giving them that
space and stuff and these women were
coming up to me they're like i love your
mother and like
the time before i saw my mom like we
were like holding hands and crying and
just being like i'm so great like
just really like having these like and
you know my parents are like older it's
like i want to only have like that love
for them and i want to just have that
for everyone like i don't want to have
any like
[ __ ] between us or any you know anyone
like i just wanted to be like good
i saw my grandma did she [ __ ] with you
did she let you in
it we i feel like we it was good
breakthrough i thought you know why
i i saw her be mean
to other people and it instantly like
made me like oh when she's mean to me
it's not about me
yeah i'm not special i'm not this like
thing she hates she's just kind of mean
sometimes
she's so she's old she's cranky and that
really and
i and i also went in just very calm and
not expecting anything
and i think like i went in with the
right energy
and uh and it just
it worked and she gave me her wedding
dress
she's never really given me anything
before she likes to give to
all the women in the family and i've
kind of been left aside do you like the
dress
i do like it okay good because it's not
funny just like
thank you well you know you can molly
shannon it right not molly shannon you
can molly
uh molly ringwald it and like re yeah
like
perfect for it size it to you make it a
little bit more modern but
i actually preferred the original dress
in pretty in pink remember she bought
that dress
and then she kind of did her own thing
with it at the end all i remember is
i was in 16 candles when she gave her
underwear and i'm like why you would
have so much discharge on that underwear
to jake yeah i don't i didn't see that i
well i wonder oh my god
she's like um they didn't kill a bunch
of jews in it so i didn't watch it i
didn't
left a lot of children it wasn't really
my type of movie just didn't call for me
but i liked the wedding dress a lot it
was from her second wedding so it's
actually
i guess like maybe this is still current
or back then but if you had a second
wedding your dress was a little it was
not as big of a deal you know so it's
like it's short
it's simple is it long on you though no
she's tiny too so it fits me
and it's cream-colored it needs to be i
think re-dyed i don't know if that's
possible but it definitely needs to be
like lightened up
and maybe a little adjustments but it's
really it's like custom-made it's super
nice so
that i'm like all right well i have a
free dress like might as well try to
have a wedding so
definitely weddings are on the mind now
because of the dress look
after you are the only one that's
actually
engaged therefore you're in you're first
in line [ __ ]
you you have to go first you want to
give me a get married before you guys
yeah but you might even aren't going to
be city hall
don't count me out of city no i'm gonna
do i'll probably have the biggest
wedding
i think annie will have the biggest i
love attention
my whole family too that's what i
realized there's that look in this room
there are three weddings potentially to
be cooked up
i think that deep down i could have made
a great wedding planner i just dread the
idea of like walking down
an aisle in front of people like it just
seems to
not it's so extreme how do you just put
rudy to the just make her [ __ ]
plan her wedding for she's lives here
earn your keep playing my wedding
yeah that's true but esther you're going
first let's plan it come on let's go
we can go at the same time oh my god
that's so
sad and codependent i don't don't be
don't wait for me don't don't wait
okay donut comes down with your ring
right and then there's 75 dogs that come
down with koala's ring
randy just swallows the ring and runs
away he's got a mullet
but yeah esther your ear up first
again i would not wait for me because
i'm all talk
i've been three years at this does dave
want one
yeah he does i
i'm opening up to it but that's still
gonna
be a journey oh god i
really i'm a little scared of the bride
you could be
but it could go either way you could be
completely apathetic yeah
if you if you here's the thing if you
dare to dream
we're in trouble if you let your mind
wander to a specific thing we might be
no no no if i do a wedding it's going to
be
i'm i am going to have fun and that's my
only thing i'm going to have
fun and people i love and it's going to
be fun for everybody
because everyone you talk to they're
like i don't even remember my wedding it
was so crazy
i didn't even talk to i'm like [ __ ] no
i'm this is not a whole thing where i'm
putting it on for everybody no i'm
having fun at my wedding
i was a wedding photographer assistant
okay one of my many jobs and i
did lose that job pretty quick she said
this was her main thing she said
make sure you zip up the cases
with all the lenses just zip them up and
i was like duh of course clink clink
clink clink she was like that was 2500
i'm like oh take it out of my pay i'm
still working for her these days but so
what i did learn from that experience
though is that
if you so much of the wedding people
really want good pictures
and that [ __ ] your wedding up because
you want like to capture these memories
but you're not like you're being
we had to like boss people around yeah
your orchestra because they would give
you like a list like okay
we want like we want a picture with the
bride and her side we want a picture of
everyone together we got a picture of
the groom and his groom's men want a
picture of the groom's
groom and his grandfather and then
you're just like it's a schedule thing
so then you're grabbing them and
wrangling them and they
[ __ ] up there i want all my wedding
pictures to be so hideous
like just you know well just invite
i like felt it coming i knew something i
heard the word hideous
i was gonna say me but then my thumb
just went to you
like my hair looks cute today i have no
point at her but so does hers
yeah i brain by george i should give it
to george again i
not to be whatever brings you joy in
your wedding moments but i
am pretty tired of
seeing the whole formulaic kind of
wedding
pictures the prenup pictures like it
they all start to look the same on
instagram yeah
esther's gonna have those prenup
pictures pre-nup pictures zoomed in
everyone you know like they they just
they take a drive to joshua tree
yeah they take the it's i i and again
like
if it makes them happy whatever but like
i think i really do want hideous
pictures
i never want to like do a thing everyone
else does and i don't know if that's
like my ego or whatever but i just don't
it's just not my taste you want to be
candid photos like all the posed ones
it's just they're just kind of boring
but you know what you should do
have polaroids and then just have
everyone take them yeah and then they'll
just fall on the table
what people will just take them home the
pictures we know who would take them
home
like esther what's that popping out of
your dress
it's like the food like snacks what is
that bean boozled
okay here's here's what i think we
should just do is everyone gets a packet
can we just eat them and then you just
tell me what you think you're
experiencing
and you said everybody i'll play too oh
my god
well it's it is ah it is candy
extra flavor so okay well the smells are
a little
basically what this is is you eat a
flavor and like let's say i have a blue
one
and i have to eat it and it's either
going to taste like berry blue
or like toothpaste you have a blue one
yeah this face is not that bad what
color do you have i'll tell you which
one are you going to eat
well tell me what my options are here
why don't you eat burger king eat the
green one so the green one is either
juicy pear or booger let it look in here
uh oh it's it's booger it's grass it's
booger
it's not what color did you do booger
[Laughter]
dude i'm gonna do white oh wait no i
started one
wait white is either coconut or spoiled
milk okay the one you have to do
please do the one that's strawberry
banana strawberry banana or dead fish
that's strawberry oh i'm so mad
i really wanted what's the white one
give me give me what's a white one
white one is or is coconut or spoiled
milk
i got it to them okay i'm gonna do blue
coconut
toothpaste toothpaste isn't bad
but it's not good candy that's such a
like ester bad one
um i've never brushed my teeth it tastes
like something i put in my mouth every
day
oh my god what
another toothpaste i think that's a
spoiled milk one
i need to have a good one i know i want
a good one these are fun
no not anymore no this the fun stopped
right there
are we signing off for the week that one
tasted actually pretty rotten i don't
like it
no it tastes like dead fish but so did
every dead fish fed me on this
show wait that's all we've been eating
every week
we have an exciting episode coming up
too right yes we do
okay bye guys
[ __ ] you guys we missed our opportunity
to talk about this what about what
the weeknd and angelina jolie oh i don't
know about that
possibly a dating oh god so boring did
she adopt him